merci d'être avec nous je juge tout ma
cravate elle est moins joli que celle de
benjamin duhamel vous ferait plaisir
c'est vraiment cette fashion victim ou
que france
4 du coup comme il s'est occupé la
grotte se préoccuper des cheveux
est ce qu'on peut faire on va demander à
nicolas druide très rapidement un plan
sur la doudoune sans manches l'offre de
notre martin qui est un cas
extraordinaire elle serait prête elle a
lâché mais il faut faire une belle offre
alors pour l'instant il ya 50 ans avoue
plus que 50 euros ça oui ça vous puisque
ceci étant dit un peu de vétusté part je
parle de la doudoune et elle
se syndiquent a su si puissant proposent
de dissocier le vote des retraités des
décisions qui touchent le monde du
travail pour je cite libérer la sécu des
intérêts patrimoniaux du troisième âge
fallait à trouver salins en gros c'est
jean souhaite priver les vieux d'une
partie de leurs droits de vote alors
j'ai pas trop compris comment
techniquement c'est possible à 95 ans
ivor bolton vient de battre un record de
haut vol celui du wind walker le plus
âgé le but you're winning working se
tenir debout sur les ailes d'un avion en
vol un défi fou réalisé pendant 1h20 par
cet arrière grand père passionné
d'aviation selon certaines personnes de
gauche les vieux n'ont pas bien voter le
sondage est là pour bfm tv révèle qu'au
premier tour de la présidentielle
les plus de 65 ans aux les plus de 65
ans ont choisi macron pour 41% le pen
pour 17% et mélenchon pour seulement 11
% d'entre eux le problème n'est pas
simplement ce que propose la cgt mais
cette petite musique qui monte
sournoisement dans le pays et qui pointe
de plus en plus du doigt nos seniors qui
est des gens qui sont allés dans la rue
se sont accordés les mecs il ya un truc
le tournoi est annulée sans rigoler et
nathan qui vient de tomber oh là là
c'est une grosse tuile
fait pas de commentaire merci il ya une
grosse grosse une qui vient de tomber
on les présente comme des insupportables
privilégie privilégiés et des gens qui
ne sont plus vraiment dans la société
bah moi ça me fait peur ce que respecter
le vote de nos aînés et ne pas faire de
discrimination
eh bien voyez vous les amis c'est ça la
france
chants de la wii champ
deux camps si tu devais mourir demain
quand même si plus lien un fait
important
je les tiens non franchement ya c'est un
truc que je vous dirais que j'apprends
la nouvelle on dirait
françois hollande appelle à voter pour
emmanuel macron
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la fille de macron était été
vandalisée
s'est pas tu sais on a toujours gardé
d'en essayer celle de mélenchon
par contre les rideaux et les retrouver
elle est en pleine forme il a
légèrement rider
vous avez pas voter c'est ma possession
des pères un malaise je vais faire la
fête
et alors c'est pas possible
ah bon dieu voilà à noter que malgré son
désespoir elle n'a pas oublié de mettre
un petit filtre sur jordan bardet l'art
est plus sympa comme ça qui aurait pu
penser que kad merad se retrouvent
récité en 2022 lors d'un débat entre les
représentants des deux finalistes de la
présidentielle attention à pas le cas de
mme érables de baron noir la série
politique ça aurait pu faire sans ce
moment vous ayez un sketch le cadre
merad c'est jean-michel à peu près là
ces jeunes avaient séjourné oui vous
avez bien jean-michel comptable en
excuser moi arrêter les débats la
prochaine fois prêté à géo dire on n'a
pas froid aux yeux
we do
we
grave